>>Debajit Ghosh: Hi. I am Debajit Ghosh. I
lead the Android Sync Team at Google, and
I am delighted to talk to you about how you
can build push applications for the Android
platform.
You can view live notes and ask questions
on the Wave at the following URL.
During this talk, we are going to cover how
many Android applications access data in the
cloud. One of the fundamental challenges for
those applications is how do you keep data
on the device fresh? How do you keep the data
up-to-date?
There are two basic techniques, polling and
pushing.
I am going to talk about each, and we are
going to see, ultimately, you typically don't
want to use polling in your applications.
You want to use push.
We're then going to go through the APIs for
the new Android cloud-to-device messaging
framework that we have announced here at Google
I/O and we're going to see how easy it is
to build push applications on Android.
We are going to go through the APIs in detail,
go through design considerations, and then
we are going to wrap up with a demo.
Anybody here have an Android phone?
[ Laughter ]
>>Debajit Ghosh: Okay. Maybe that's not a
fair question. Anybody here have two Android
phones?
Oh, wait.
[ Laughter ]
>>Debajit Ghosh: These are tremendous devices.
They have got incredible browsers, and they
can run really powerful, very compelling applications.
So the most interesting applications are those
that access data in the cloud, giving you
seamless access to your data wherever you
are.
You can have applications like mobile alerts.
Your favorite hockey team just scored a goal
in overtime and is moving on to the next round
of the playoffs, and you want to know the
second that happened. You can have send-to-phone
applications. You are looking at a map, you
are looking at driving directions, you are
looking at driving directions on the desktop.
You don't want to be looking at driving directions
on the desktop. You want to the driving directions
on the phone where you can use navigation
to get to where you want to go.
With a simple click of the button, you can
send a map, send a Web page to your phone
easily.
There are background sync applications. You
want to make use -- you want to access your
data, you want to make use of your data wherever
you are, whether you are online or off-line.
You want that data to sync to your device
transparently. And when you make changes to
your data in the cloud, when you make changes
on the Web, you want to make sure that the
latest data is reflected on your device as
quickly as possible.
Across all of these types of applications
there is one fundamental challenge: How do
you keep data on your device fresh? How do
you keep your data up-to-date?
There are two basic techniques, polling and
pushing.
Polling is a fairly simple to implement technique.
In polling, your application periodically
asks your server, hey, has anything changed?
Is there any new data for me?
It's pretty simple to implement.
But a lot of times the data in the cloud isn't
changing that frequently. So polling can take
a bit of a toll on a battery. This is because
whenever you are accessing data, whenever
you are using the data network, you are powering
up the radio. When you use the radio, you
are consuming power. Even when you are done
accessing data, the radio stays on for a couple
of seconds.
So this can take a little bit of a toll on
a battery.
Polling is, however, completely appropriate
for some types of content. If you have content
that's actually changing constantly, like
stock quotes, news headlines, and your application
is tolerant of showing slightly stale data,
you can poll very infrequently, and then when
the user is actually starting to view that
data, is trying to access that data, your
application can refresh the data immediately.
Let's take a look at the impact on a battery
when you poll.
This is one of the routine measurements that
we take on the Android team. It shows a typical
poll.
In the baseline, when a device is idle, it
might even have an open TCP connection with
the server, but there's no data being transmitted
or receive. The baseline power draw is about
five to ten milliamps. But when you start
accessing data, if you are reading data, that
power usage can jump up to 115 milliamps.
If you are writing data, transmitting data
can be more expensive than reading, that power
usage jumps up to 180, 200 or more milliamps.
So for a short poll here, you might have consumed
2.5 milliamp hours and that can add up.
If your application is polling every five
minutes, then that adds up to 144 milliamp
hours. That's quite a bit of a battery. A
battery typically gives you 1200 to 1400 milliamp
hours, so that's over 10% of a battery from
one application that's polling every five
minutes.
If you scale back your polling to every 15
minutes, you do a little bit better. You consume
about 48 milliamp hours.
What does this mean? How does this affect
our design? When do we want to poll?
Like everything else in engineering, there
is a tradeoff and here there is a tradeoff
between freshness and efficiency.
If you poll very frequently, you will have
very fresh data, for your application is not
going to be as efficient.
Poll less frequently and your data is not
going to be as fresh, but you will be a little
bit better on the battery.
So let's take a step back. What is it that
we ultimately want here?
When do we want to poll?
Well, typically, ultimately we don't want
to poll. We want to push.
Push-based systems provide both freshness
and efficiency, and they do that by only making
use of data when it's useful.
In a push system, an application or a service
will establish and maintain a connection,
a persistent connection, with a server in
the cloud. And that allows that server in
the cloud to send data to the application
when something has actually changed.
If you use an Android device, chances are
you are already making use of push functionality.
The Google contacts, calendar, and of course
Gmail sync functionality that ships on many
Android devices makes use of push. Google
Voice makes use of push. And Android Market
makes use of push, like Vic showed in his
demo this morning.
Anybody can implement a push-based system
on the Android platform. The Android APIs,
the SDK allow anyone to run a background service
to establish or maintain a connection.
Have any of you tried to build a push-based
system on Android? A couple of you.
If you have tried, no doubt you have noticed
that there's a couple of details to work through.
There are some things that you have to make
sure you do to make that push-based system
work well, to work efficiently.
So it can be somewhat tricky to implement.
Well, I'm delighted to share with you all
of the time and energy, all of the work that
we have put into making push work for Google
applications and opening it up to all of you
as Android cloud-to-device messaging.
Android cloud to device messaging is a new
Google API that we are launching in labs.
It's initially going to be available as a
small trial to developers and then we are
going to open it up to all developers later
this year.
Android cloud-to-device messaging requires
Android 2.2 to be on the device as well as
Android Market. Android Market is required
simply for a technical requirement to make
sure the underlying cloud-to-device messaging
functionality is there and present on the
device.
Of course, you have a choice. You have the
freedom to deploy your application however
you want, on Market or on your own Web site.
Android cloud-to-device messaging makes use
of the existing persistent connection that's
already used to power push in Google applications.
So that persistent connection is well amortized
across a number of applications.
With Android cloud-to-device messaging, your
servers can send lightweight data messages
to your applications on devices, and this
is typically used to tell your application
when something has changed. This is how you
can tell your application, hey, now is a good
time to sync.
When an Android cloud to device message is
received on the device, it is concerted into
an intent, which is well integrated with the
REST of the Android platform. That intent
is broadcast, it's actually broadcast specifically
to your application through the use of permissions,
and then that allows your application to do
whatever it wants.
With Android cloud to device messaging, if
you want some UI component, your application
supplies it. You can do whatever you want.
If you want a notification, you can use the
Android notification framework to put one
up.
But if you are working on a background sync
application, you might not need any UI. All
you are trying to do is make sure that data
syncs transparently in the background.
If you do want to have a UI, if you want to
put up a notification, for example, typically
what you do is you go ahead and fetch the
new data first, then put up the notification.
So that way when the user selects the notification,
they can immediately access the new data.
Android cloud to device messaging is a best-effort
service. We try really, really hard to make
sure that each and every message gets through.
We store messages reliably for delivery to
devices that might be having network problems,
might be temporarily off-line.
But every once in a while a message could
get lost, be delivered out of order, and it's
just something that you need to keep in mind
when you design your application to make sure
you are robust to that.
If you are like me, you like to know how things
work. So let's go ahead and take a peek under
the hood of how we built Android cloud to
device messaging.
First, we built out a set of servers to manage
those persistent connections from all the
Android devices. And we have scaled those
servers so they can handle connections from
each and every Android device.
On the device, we have a background service
that establishes and maintenance that connection.
Of course, we honor the background data setting
and don't do this work if the user has deselected
background data, indicating that they don't
want any data to be consumed in the background.
This service starts when the network first
comes up.
Once we first go ahead and establish that
connection, we work really, really hard to
make sure that that connection stays alive.
We make use of application-level heartbeats
to keep that connection alive. This is because
on a wide-area network, there's a couple of
challenges.
First, there are a lot of components on a
wide-area network, like NATs and IP load balancers
that try and find, detect idle connections
and kill those connections.
In addition, there's actually an interesting
phenomena known as half-open connections that
we have encountered on various networks. And
with the half-open connection, an application
might be able to send data in one direction,
but it can't receive data in the other direction.
So we use our heartbeating protocol to detect
when that happens and reconnect.
We also do everything we can to make this
connection as efficient as possible. This
connection is SSL encrypted, and we have built
a distributed, scalable SSL session resumption
system, so that way each time a device reconnects,
it doesn't have to redownload a 2 to 3K SSL
certificate.
Whenever you have an open TCP connection,
if there is no data being transmitted or received,
there is very little overhead, very little
power consumption, as we saw. However, whenever
you start accessing the radio, including for
heartbeats, that draws power.
So we have worked really hard to minimize
our heartbeat frequency. We have actually
tuned this for a lot of different networks
to minimize that heartbeat frequency, making
sure that the connection stays alive, but
otherwise try to make sure that it's spaced
out as much as possible.
And we also minimize the number of concurrent
connections that we establish and maintain
on a device. For Android cloud to device messaging,
each Android device just uses one persistent
connection.
Let's take a closer look at heartbeats.
With heartbeats, when one side hasn't heard
anything from the other side for some period
of time, it will go ahead and send a ping.
The other side, upon receiving the ping, will
send back an ack, and when the originating
side receives that ack, it knows everything
is cool. Connection is alive.
If, however, one side sends a ping and doesn't
get back an ack, it knows that the connection
is dead and it needs to reconnect.
To implement heartbeats, we use the Android
alarm framework. We use this to schedule the
initial heartbeat, and then whenever we receive
any kind of data over that connection, we
know the connection is alive, and we cancel
that pending heartbeat and reschedule it.
When we actually do go ahead and issue a ping,
we schedule an alarm to wait for the ack to
come back in a timely fashion. If it doesn't
come back, we know the connection is dead
and we reconnect.
And we actually have this same protocol on
the server side.
The server side can also initiate heartbeats.
On the server side, since the servers can't
reconnect to the devices, the devices are
typically behind a NAT or something like that,
we mainly use this to detect a dead connection
and clean up some state.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the overall
life cycle for Android cloud-to-device messaging.
There are three basic phases, first, up-front,
a device, an application on device, we'll
go ahead and enable Android cloud-to-device
messaging.
It does this with a registration API, and
with this registration API, each application
on a device gets a unique RegistrationID.
When this application gets its RegistrationID,
it sends that to its server.
That way, the server can use that for sending
messages.
In the run-time portion, per-message, when
an application server wants to send a message,
it issues a very simple HTTP post to some
servers at Google.
When the Google servers receive that HTTP
post, they store the message and queue it
for delivery, for reliable delivery, to the
device, and things are good to go.
Then, if an application wants to disable push,
if it wants to disable cloud-to-device messaging,
it can use a simple unregister API.
And you might do this if, for example, you
have a background sync application and the
user unselects the auto sync check box.
Let's take a closer look at that run-time
portion.
Let's look at the life of a message.
Here, Android device already established a
connection with our connection servers.
An application server will go ahead and send
that simple HTTP post to our cloud-to-device
messaging frontends.
We receive that request, store the message,
route the request to the appropriate connection
server that's housing a connection from the
target device, which will go ahead and send
the message to the device.
At this point, two things will happen, basically,
in parallel.
First, that -- that message will be converted
into an intent, which is broadcast to wake
up or start up an application.
In addition, the device will acknowledge receipt
of that message so we can clear that from
our store.
The application wakes up, and then it can
go ahead and fetch its latest data from its
application server.
Overall, the design here is to make sure that
the state, the relevant state typically remains
in the application server, not in the message.
Let's take a look at some code.
To register, your application makes use of
a very simple intent-based API.
You create an intent and populate it with
a little bit of data.
You populate with information about your application,
and you also provide it a role account that
your application server is going to use when
it sends messages.
This role account has nothing to do with any
of the accounts on the Android device.
Again, this is a role account that your application
server is going to use when it sends messages.
And you go ahead and call start service.
And then sometime later, your application
will receive an intent back with the RegistrationID.
When you receive that RegistrationID, go ahead
and send that to your application servers.
The Android cloud-to-device messaging framework
might reissue or rotate these registration
IDs from time to time.
So your intent receiver that's receiving these
registration intents might be called again
in the future.
And if that happens, all you do is do the
same thing that you did in the first place.
Take that RegistrationID and send it to your
server.
Here's some code that shows you what -- how
you can go ahead and process that registration
intent.
You have an intent receiver on receive.
Check for that registration intent, and then
go ahead and see whether or not you got a
RegistrationID.
If you did, cool.
Send it to your server.
If you get back an error, then you should
retry with some backoff.
To send messages, your application servers
send a very simple HTTP post.
This request is authenticated using the ac2dm
authentication token, which you typically
grab once up-front, using the client login
API, and install into your servers.
You include this authentication token in the
authorization header.
And then you also include a couple of URL
encoded parameters.
You include the RegistrationID for the target
application and device.
You include a collapse key, which controls
how messages are delivered when a device is
offline.
And you can also specify an optional delay
while idle parameter, as well as some small
amount of payload in the form of arbitrary
key value pairs.
We're going to talk about each of these parameters
in turn.
When you issue that HTTP post, you'll typically
get one of three response codes back, a 200,
a 401, or a 303.
If you get back a 401, that means that your
authentication token is no longer valid.
So you need to grab a new one.
And this could happen if, for example, you
change the password for your role account.
If you get back a 503, then you should retry
your request with backoff.
And please honor any retry after headers that
you receive.
If you get back a 200, that means that your
request was syntactically valid, and if you
get an ID in the response, everything's cool.
We got the message and are going to route
it to a device.
If, however, you get back an error, one of
several things could have happened.
If we start detecting an unusual or excessive
amount of messaging from a sender in aggregate
across devices or from a sender to a specific
device, then you'll hit some quota limits.
And when you do that, you need to back off
and try again later.
If the RegistrationID that you supplied was
invalid or if the application requested unregistration,
then we'll tell you that, and you need to
wait until you get a new RegistrationID from
the application before you try sending messages
to that target device again.
If the message you sent was too big, the payload
is limited to being about 1K.
Or if you didn't supply a collapse key, you
need to fix these issues before you try again.
When a message is received on the device,
it's converted into an intent.
That intent is broadcast.
And through the use of permissions that your
application defines and requests, that intent
is sent only to your application.
When that intent is broadcast, your application
is woken up or it's started.
So that means that your application doesn't
need to be sitting there running in the background.
You don't need to have some service running
continually.
Your application will wake up.
Any payload that you provided will be converted
into the extras in the intent, and you can
do whatever you need to do.
If you're going to be doing anything nontrivial,
typically, you'll grab a WakeLock.
Don't forget to release the WakeLock when
you're done.
And you'll do whatever processing you need
to do in a service.
And you can use the intent service API to
simplify your work here.
And that's it.
That's all there is to the API.
First, you call registration to get your RegistrationID.
Next, in the run-time portion, you issue a
simple HTTP post to send messages.
And then, if your application chooses to not
make use of push anymore, for example, if
the user deselects auto sync, you can unregister.
It's a pretty simple API.
We found that most developers who were trying
out the API can get something up and running
in a matter of hours.
We're now going to talk about some of the
options and design considerations you need
to keep in mind when you're making use of
Android cloud-to-device messaging.
The first concept we're going to talk about
is that of message collapse.
When a device is offline for any period of
time, we want to avoid message delivery explosion
when that device comes online again.
A lot of times, say, in a mail application,
one "you have new mail" message is as good
as any of the other ones.
So if you're on a flight, when you come off
the flight, you don't need to receive tens
or hundreds of those messages.
You just need one.
And so when you send a message, you can supply
a collapse key.
And that collapse key controls how those messages
are stored and delivered.
Typically, you specify a collapse key to correspond
with some topic or some feed, whatever, that
is meaningful to your application, perhaps
a URL that your application's going to hit
to get its data.
And when a message is sent to our servers
with a collapse key, if there are any outstanding
undelivered messages already stored under
that collapse key, the new one will overwrite
the previous ones.
This really emphasizes the design principle
of keeping your state in your server, not
in the messages.
And we find that this allows for very clean
design and allows you to decouple your messaging
channel from, for instance, your synchronization
channel.
That way, the same code that you use for,
say, a manual refresh can make use of the
synchronization channel as is, and all you're
doing when you receive a cloud-to-device message
is kick off that -- that code.
Let's take a look at how this works.
Here, we have a device that happens to be
offline.
It's on the proverbial airplane.
Your application server, as usual, sends a
cloud-to-device message to our frontends.
We receive it, store it.
But then we don't route it to any connection
servers because the device is not connected.
The application server sends a subsequent
message under the same collapse key.
We'll receive that message, and that new message
will overwrite the previous message.
You can specify whatever collapse key you
want on a message-by-message basis.
But there's a limitation.
Each application can have, at most, four messages
or four unique collapse keys outstanding at
any given time.
The next concept we're going to talk about
is attenuation.
We want to make sure that data on a device
is fresh, but we also want to protect a user's
battery.
We want to protect the radio.
Whenever a cloud-to-device message is received
on a device, that fires up the radio.
And we want to make sure that the radio isn't
constantly firing up.
So if we detect that a specific application
is sending a high frequency of cloud-to-device
messages, we'll let the first few of those
through quickly.
We want to make sure that things are fresh.
But then we're going to start holding on to
those messages for a short period of time
to make sure that the radio is not firing
constantly.
Attenuation is done on an application on a
collapse key basis.
Let's take a look.
Here we have Android device, and it's connected
to our connection servers.
And the application server has already been
sending a bunch of messages recently.
It'll send a new message to our cloud-to-device
messaging frontends.
We'll receive the message, store it, and send
it to the connection server.
At that point, we'll hold onto the message
for a short period of time.
And then we'll send it to the device.
Attenuation is a way that we automatically
try and protect battery and delay message
delivery.
There's also a technique that you can opt
into to be even more aggressive about delaying
messages, and that's by making use of the
delay while idle feature.
Each Android device tells our servers when
their screen is on or off.
It does this efficiently.
And by knowing when a screen is off, we know
that the device isn't actively being used.
And there are certain classes of content where
data changes very frequently but might not
be of much interest if the device isn't being
used.
For example, in a chat application, you might
not care about the latest presence updates,
which can change very frequently, when the
device is in your pocket.
You might not care about your friends' latest
location information, again, when the device
is on a table or in your desk.
And so on a message-by-message basis, your
application servers can specify the delay
while idle parameter.
And when that's specified, our connection
servers will hold on to one of these messages
while the screen is off for the target device,
and then it will deliver that message immediately,
as soon as the device becomes active again.
Let's take a look.
Here we have Android device.
It's connected to our connection servers,
but the screen is off.
It's asleep.
The application server goes ahead and sends
a message to our front-ends, which, as usual,
we store, route to the connection server,
but at this point, the connection server is
going to hold on to the message.
It's going to hold on to the message until
the device actually becomes active again.
When the user starts using the device, turns
-- turns the screen on, we'll then immediately
send the message to the device.
Now that we've taken a look at the APIs and
all of the design considerations, let's see
what we can do when we put all of this together
and build some real applications.
The first application we're going to talk
about is the Google Chrome-to-phone extension
that Vic demoed this morning.
This is going to be one of the sample applications
for Android cloud-to-device messaging.
In fact, you can already see all of the code
on code.google.com/P/ Chrometophone.
The really great thing about this, in addition
to being a really useful application, this
is one of the things that I've wanted for
a long time, the application was built by
an engineer who was just kicking the tires
on our API while he was on a flight.
So he built this really quickly.
And I think it really shows some of the really
cool applications that you can build with
cloud-to-device messaging.
If you didn't see the keynote, the Google
Chrome-to-phone extension is a simple Chrome
extension that allows you to send any Web
page or a map or a YouTube video or whatever
from the Web to your Android device.
It's powered by, of course, a small Android
application and an also very simple App Engine
back-end.
Let's take a look at how this works.
First, you go ahead and view some Web page
in Chrome.
The user will then go ahead and click on the
Chrome-to-phone extension, which makes a request
to the App Engine back-end.
The App Engine back-end then issues a request
through the Android cloud-to-device messaging
service, which will go ahead and send the
message to the target device.
The user can then select a notification or
you can disable that and have automatic updates
on the phone.
And then the Android device will fire up the
browser, go to the origin server, and get
the latest data.
If you want to look at this in more detail,
you can go ahead and look at the open source
example.
The next demo we're going to take a look at
is JumpNote.
JumpNote is a fully-featured, two-way push
sync notes sample application.
It makes use of App Engine on the back-end
and the Web UI is powered by GWT.
It's also going to be one of the open source
sample applications that we ship with Android
cloud-to-device messaging.
And this will show you how to make use of
the Android sync framework that we shipped
in Android 2.0.
In addition, it also shows you how to use
the new cloud-to-device to enable push sync
for your sync applications.
When the cloud-to-device message is received
on the device, the intent receiver simply
kicks off a sync, just calls the request sync
API.
And that's all it needs to do, and then sync
happens as normal.
Let's go ahead and take a look.
So here I have the JumpNote application.
There's no data here.
And I'm going to go ahead and create a new
note.
I'm going to go ahead and save the note.
And now we're going to switch to the ELMO.
And on the ELMO, we can see the JumpNote application
running on the device.
What's happening here?
Well, when I clicked on "save," the GWT application
saved the data in the App Engine data store.
It then used the App Engine task queue API
to send the HTTP post for the cloud-to-device
messaging request.
Our servers got that request, stored the message,
routed the message to the right connection
server, sent the message to the device, which
converted to an intent, broadcast the intent.
The JumpNote application woke up, did its
sync.
And all of that happened in far less time
than I took to explain everything that was
going on.
Anyone here interested in trying out Android
cloud-to-device messaging?
>>> Yeah!
>>Debajit Ghosh: Well, I'm delighted to tell
you that we're launching Android cloud-to-device
messaging in Labs now, and we're accepting
sign-ups.
[ Applause ]
>>Debajit Ghosh: If you want to find out more,
if you want to read our documentation, see
the open source code examples, or sign up,
go ahead and visit code.google.com/Android/c2dm.
You can also Google search for that if you
didn't grab the URL.
During this talk, we've seen how many Android
applications access data in the cloud.
And to provide freshness for those applications,
to be both fresh and efficient, we've seen
that you want to use push to keep data on
those devices fresh and up-to-date.
And by using the Android cloud-to-device messaging
framework, you can do that simply.
Android cloud-to-device messaging makes building
push applications simple, easy, and efficient.
If you want to find out more, you can sign
up now at code.google.com/Android.C2DM.
We're going to go ahead and switch over to
the moderator link to look at any questions.
If you also have questions, you can go up
to the microphones and ask them at this time.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Debajit Ghosh: Are there any live questions?
Go ahead.
>>> I was wondering, what is the typical latency
that you're experiencing?
>>Debajit Ghosh: I'm sorry.
I couldn't hear the question.
>>> What is the typical latency from the time
that a -- the server pushes the message to
your server and it -- the intent shows up
on the -- on the phone?
>>Debajit Ghosh: It's typically on the order
of seconds.
It varies, obviously, depending on the network
and, you know -- both the network between
your server and our servers, and the network
between our servers and the device.
But it's pretty quick.
>>> Okay.
>>> Is there an API or a mechanism to go the
other way around, from the device back to
the Web to do something like a two-way chat
in the same manner?
>>Debajit Ghosh: Typically, what applications
do is they'll just go ahead and make use of
regular HTTP integration with their application
servers.
>>> Hi.
Two questions.
You said that you need 2.2 Froyo in the market
for this right now.
Does that mean that support for the emulators
will come in later?
>>Debajit Ghosh: I'm sorry, can you say that
again.
>>> What about support for emulators?
Because you'll be needing 2.2 and the market?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The 2.2 SDK will provide
support for this.
So you can test out your applications on that
SDK.
>>> Okay.
And I had a second question.
Does the code side also have code for the
App Engine side of the code?
>>Debajit Ghosh: Yes, absolutely.
It's fully featured.
So the Chrome-to-phone example has the Chrome
extension, the Android application, and the
App Engine back-end.
The JumpNote example has the GWT and App Engine
samples as well as the Android applications.
We're giving you everything.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> Yeah, you said that, like, if the phone
is idle, the server will hold the message
and won't deliver it until the phone is, like,
busy.
So how would you define when the phone is
idle?
It is possible that the user, they run the
application, like, as a service in the background
and leave it on the table, and then the screen
turn off and things like that.
So how would you define, you know, like when
the phone is idle?
Because that's obvious -- might be waiting
for the messages.
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, I believe,
how do you determine when a phone is idle.
>>> Yes.
>>Debajit Ghosh: Is that the question?
We do it based on whether or not the screen
is off.
If the screen has been off for some period
of time, we deem that phone to be idle, inactive,
because the user's not actually looking at
anything on the phone.
>>> But then again, like, the application,
it might run the service in the background
and, you know, like, the service might be
waiting for the message.
>>Debajit Ghosh: If you don't want to use
the delay while idle option, you don't have
to.
That's something that you can do for types
of data where you want that behavior.
Does that answer your question?
>>> Oh, can you come again, please?
>>Debajit Ghosh: I'm sorry, I'm having trouble
hearing.
>>> Can you explain it again for me, please.
So if the service is waiting for the message
and the screen is, like, turned off, like,
how can you avoid that situation?
>>Debajit Ghosh: So the question was, how
do you avoid having your messages be delayed
--
>>> Yes.
>>Debajit Ghosh: -- when the screen turns
off?
If you don't want that behavior, you don't
specify the delay while idle parameter.
That's an optional parameter.
>>> Oh, I see.
Thank you.
>>> Yes, hello.
Is there any ability to push a message against
a certain time zone or locality?
>>Debajit Ghosh: Let me repeat the question.
The question was, is there a way to push a
message to a certain time zone or locality?
>>> For instance, like, a country-specific
or something of that sort.
>>Debajit Ghosh: Are you talking about localization?
>>> Yes.
>>Debajit Ghosh: That's something that's going
to be up to your application.
So typically, again, what you're doing with
these cloud-to-device messages is sending
something that, you know, tickles, wakes up
your device, wakes up your application so
it can go ahead and do whatever it needs to
do.
There's no UI component inherent to Android
cloud-to-device messaging.
That's something that your application supplies.
Does that answer your question?
>>> Yeah, more or less.
>>> Hi.
So you mentioned that it's only available
in 2.2.
And so for previous -- like, right now, I
think everybody don't have 2.2, right, and
a lot of phones will not upgrade to that.
So would that be back-ported somehow?
And will -- what's your recommendation on
dealing with older phones that not have that
version?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, this functionality
is only available for Android 2.2.
Will this functionality be back-ported.
The answer is no.
This is one of the new features.
There's a lot of new features.
We're always trying to innovate.
We're always trying to build out new functionality.
This is one of the new features in 2.2.
>>> In that case, we can do polling as before?
That's what you recommend?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, in that
case, we'd do polling as before on older applications
-- on older devices?
Yeah, you'd do polling or you can -- again,
from day one, anyone can build their own push-based
system.
So you could go ahead and build that if you
wanted.
>>> One more question.
Do you profile, like, a broadcast capability,
where right now you're saying the phone has
to register for that message and you will
go ahead and send it.
But there's a way, like, for any phones that
have registered that has installed my app,
is there a way I can just send a message to
everyone and let them know about certain information?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, is there
any way to send a message that is broadcast
to all devices.
No.
The RegistrationID is a per-app, per-device
ID.
It provides compartmentilization of apps and
devices.
So that one, one sender can't send messages
to another application.
So there's no way to do that.
You'd have to issue a series of cloud-to-device
messages on your server side.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> What are the quotas?
And is pricing available?
>>Debajit Ghosh: I'm sorry, can you repeat
the question?
>>> Is the service free?
Is there a pricing available?
Is there quota limitations of how many messages
the application can send a day?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, what is
the pricing.
The pricing is free.
What are the limitations?
There are quota limitations.
Basically, what we're trying to do is look
out for excessive usage in aggregate by a
sender or by a sender to a specific device.
And if you find that you end up running into
those -- into issues with that, we can discuss
and talk about quotas.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>> Two questions.
One is, is there a way to specify a TTL for
a message, that it should not be delivered
after a certain amount of time. So just in
case the user is offline at that point in
time, the message will expire after, let's
say, two minutes and after two minutes it
--
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, is there
a way to specify a TTL on a message.
The answer is, no, not currently.
But if that's some other kind of functionality
you're interested in, we'll take that as feedback.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>> In your example with polling every five
minutes, you said that that could use 5 to
10% of your battery over a day with that operation.
Can you describe what mechanisms you use with
your -- your cloud-to-device to reduce the
impact of that communication on the battery
life of the phone.
For example, you respond within two seconds,
when the screen is off, that kind of thing.
How are you keeping the battery usage down.
>>Debajit Ghosh: I'm sorry, I'm having trouble
with the audio.
Can you repeat the question?
You were talking about the --
>>> I'm curious how you were keeping the battery
usage down on your own cloud-to-device messaging
infrastructure, 'cause you know when the screen
is on or off, and you're keeping track of
things and you have quick response to messages.
How do you keep from using much power with
that?
>>Debajit Ghosh: Well, the fundamental idea
here is, we have one connection.
We amortize that connection across a lot of
applications.
And when there's no traffic being transmitted
or received over that connection, there's
very little power draw.
And so what we've done is, we actually space
out our heartbeats to be, you know, much less
frequent than every five minutes.
We make sure that those heartbeats are spaced
out pretty far apart.
So for an idle device, for a device that's
not getting data, there's not much impact
on battery.
Of course, if you're going ahead and making
more use -- if there's a lot of messages that
are coming down, then that will cause radio
wakeups, it will impact battery.
And that's why we have features like attenuation.
And that's also why we have features that
you can opt into, like delay while idle.
So that way, you know for your application
domain you don't need to have messages sent
to an otherwise idle device, so you can afford
to have them be delayed.
>>> Thank you.
>>> So that said (Off mike) >>Debajit Ghosh:
The question was, that said, is there a five-minute
latency in the system?
Not at all.
The heartbeats are not five minutes, in fact.
We have those heartbeats in place, and they're
much less frequent than every five minutes,
on the order of, you know, sometimes half
an hour.
And we had those heartbeats in place just
to keep the connection alive.
Because once you've established that connection,
you only keep it alive because reconnecting
can be a bit more expensive.
So we're just trying to keep that connection
alive.
While that connection is alive, messages will
be sent very, very quickly.
There shouldn't be, you know, on the order
of five-minute latency.
>>> Do you have any plans or is this compliant
with OMA push specifications?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question is, is there
any integration here with OMA push, are there
any plans to integrate with OMA push.
Not at this time.
>>> So, basically, if I have a push server,
I cannot use it.
I have to go through the one that Google sets
up; correct?
>>Debajit Ghosh: If you want to use Android
-- the question was, if you have a push server,
you wouldn't be able to use that here.
That's correct.
You'd have to -- if you want to make use of
Android cloud-to-device messaging, you have
to use the Android cloud-to-device APIs.
If you want to build out support for OMA push,
you know, this is Android.
You can build the service on the application
or you can install, you know -- if someone
else has built one, you can install that on
a device and that can go ahead and connect
to the OMA push servers.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Okay.
You said that you amortize the connection
across multiple applications.
The default applications that are shipping
out that are used by Google which use push
services, do those also use exactly this connection?
Or do they have a separate connection and
this is only for applications -- applications
by developers?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, is this
the same connection that's used for the Google
functionality or is there a separate connection?
This is the exact same connection.
So we're -- we're using this functionality.
We've been using this functionality, you know,
since day one to enable push for GMail contacts
and calendar sync, for a lot of other functionality.
We're just basically opening this up to all
of you now.
>>> Is there a way for the user to specify
that he's okay with a high frequency of updates
during some periods of the day, like in the
morning, and then in the afternoon, say I
want very few messages during this time?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, is there
a way to specify an application's okay with
latency during periods of time and wants more
freshness during other periods of time.
There's nothing like that.
That's something that you would -- That's
the kind of logic that you would build out
in your application server at the point when
you're issuing the messages.
>>> Right.
But if I was too frequent, Google would scale
me back; right?
If I -- if I send messages too frequently,
then your servers will -- will back off; right?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, if the
application's sending too frequently, will
Google scale that back.
Yes, that's what we do with attenuation.
And there's no way to specify, you know, hints
or policies of what you'd like, you know,
in the form of attenuation.
>>> Thank you.
>>> So I have small question.
The first is, how do you guarantee the security
of the message?
I mean, sometimes the message can be some
sensitive information.
How do you guarantee the security?
I mean, do you use any encryption or something
like that to process?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, how do
you guarantee the security of a message if
a message contains some sensitive data? Do
we use encryption.
That persistent connection is SSL-encrypted.
But remember, the overall design here is not
to have state in the message.
Don't -- I mean, you know, if you want to
have something sensitive in that message,
you can encrypt it.
You can do that with the arbitrary payload.
That's something you can do on an application
level.
Or don't send anything sensitive down that
pipe.
Just tickle your application and then have
your application fetch its sensitive data
directly.
That's the kind of design that we've made
use of in building our own sync functionality.
>>> Right.
So basically, basically, C2D is not suitable
for sensitive use case; right?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, Android
cloud-to-device isn't suitable for sensitive
information.
And, again, I think that's something you can
work through in your design by using the techniques
that I talked about.
That you can control on the application side.
>>> Right.
The other question is, how do you guarantee
the authentication?
I mean, someone asked me maybe what -- someone
might steal my RegistrationID and pretend
to be me and address it to the server.
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was, how do
you authenticate these requests.
>>> Right.
>>Debajit Ghosh: How do you make sure that
someone else doesn't steal your RegistrationID.
There's two bits of information here.
One is the role account that you specify when
you create the registration.
And we make sure that when an application
server tries to issue a message to a RegistrationID,
that the authentication credentials for the
HTTP post match that role account.
So it's up to you.
I mean, it's a password.
It's something that you should keep safe or
secret on your own.
Don't -- don't start giving out that password,
for example.
That's why you can also use a role account.
And the second thing is, there's a per-app,
per-device RegistrationID.
And that's also something that, you know,
your application gets and can send to your
server.
Don't give that out, either.
All right?
Those are two bits of information that you
need to send a message to an app on a device.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>Debajit Ghosh: Let's go ahead and see if
there's any -- any offline questions and questions
on moderator.
I think we answered the first question, which
is, this requires Android 2.2.
Second question, could you discuss the relationship
between cloud-to-device in the core Android
SDK and any dependency on Google services.
The Android cloud-to-device messaging API
is a Google service that's supported on Android
2.2 devices.
A Google account is required on the device.
Of course, your application doesn't need to
think about or worry about that account.
You can use whatever authentication credentials
make sense for your domain.
But to establish or maintain that connection,
a Google account needs to be on the device.
So there is a dependency on Google services.
The next question was about Market, and I
think we already answered that.
What is -- the next question is what's the
data format? Or is that also up to us?
The data format, if you are going to be sending
some payload, it's arbitrary key value pairs
that you set in your HTTP post, and you can
those values be whatever you want it to be.
>>> What's the max size of the message and
how long will it last in Google servers before
it's delivered to a user, in case the user
is off-line?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question is what's the
max size per message. Max size is 1K.
The second question, I had a little bit of
trouble W how do we make sure the message
gets to the device?
>>> No. How long will it last on your servers
till its delivered to the user in case the
user is off-line? What's the maximum amount
of time that it can survive on your servers.
>>Debajit Ghosh: On the order of weeks. Maybe
a month, you know.
>>> From the perspective of the server that's
generating the message, is it fire and forget
or can it get an ack back?
>>Debajit Ghosh: So the question is, is this
a fire-and-forget request or will the application
server get an acknowledgment back?
>>> Correct.
>>Debajit Ghosh: The application server will
get back an ID when it sends the message,
and if it gets back that ID, then the message
is on its way to a device. There's no end-to-end
acknowledgment that comes back from the application.
Typically, again, that's something you do
in your own application logic. If you want
to have that kind of functionality, when your
application receives the message, wakes up,
it can talk to your application server and
provide that acknowledgment.
>>> Right. Okay. Thanks.
>>> You may have mentioned this but I didn't
catch it. Does this work on a device that
doesn't currently have service and only has
a Wi-Fi connection? Will it go through a home
router?
>>Debajit Ghosh: The question was will this
work on Wi-Fi. Yes, as long as you have a
data connection, then the device can go ahead
and establish connection with our servers.
I mean, you know, it also is the -- you will
need that data connectivity for your application
to access data in the cloud as well.
>>> Right. Okay.
Thanks.
>>Debajit Ghosh: And I think that's it.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]